Etc on reactive synthesis thank you very
much kuldeep and yeah thanks for the
organizers for inviting me to give a
talk here
um
yeah without further Ado start with with
the talk which will be on a topic which
kind of has not uh been mentioned so far
in in the workshop namely on reactive
synthesis but I will connect of course
to a satisfiability throughout the talk
and hence the second uh somewhat uh kind
of pretentious part which is of the
title which is uh empowered biological
reasoning
uh so since this is a a session on uh
verified computation uh I will start by
briefly talking about verification
before I go uh into into synthesis so
I'll start with a brief overview of uh
sub based verification which will be uh
very quick just uh to to emphasize uh
the success that sat solvers have had in
the uh in the field of verification
uh and then I will give a brief overview
of uh synthesis of reactive systems uh
and finally I will uh dive into the the
main part of the talk uh which is uh uh
where I will discuss uh how
satisfiability and techniques uh Beyond
satisfiability uh could are useful in
the context of reactive synthesis
uh all right uh so uh
I assume that most of you are familiar
with this first part so I will go
relatively uh quickly through that
um and uh
the the goal of model checking uh of an
essentially a verification uh is uh to
formally establish uh via kind of
automated techniques uh that um uh that
a system or uh or a model of a such a
system uh satisfies a given formal
specification so the the mode of Checker
can either establish that the system is
correct and possibly provide uh some
some form of proof of that or
certificate or establish that the system
is here correct uh and provide a counter
example which is typically an execution
of a system uh that violates uh the
specification
uh now since we are here at a workshop
on satisfiability I will focus on uh
results based model checking uh where uh
so we start by uh translating the model
and the specification to propositional
formulas uh and uh then this allows
reducing uh the model checking problem
uh to to Assad problem
uh more uh more concretely uh we have a
final set of so here I'm talking about
the finite State systems uh which are uh
where the state is states of the system
are represented via final set of Boolean
variables so we have a final set of
Boolean variables and the states are
assignments to those variables uh and
then we treat we manipulate formulas
over the variables which represent sets
of States uh and uh formulas over uh the
variable oops the variables uh V and the
the prime the prime version of those
which represent sets of transitions uh
so uh by Common convention the the prime
variables here are uh the variables at
the next state of the other transition
uh so then we have a model which is
represented typically as a symbolic
transition system uh where we have our
set of variables B uh representing the
uh the states of the system uh we have a
formula I over the variables V which
represents the sets of initial States uh
and uh probability uh over V and V Prime
which represents the transition relation
of now of our symbolically represented
transition system
ah now the the specifications that uh um
we are typically interested in and here
are temporologic formulas over uh these
variables and B and an important special
case uh are uh safety properties which
are defined uh via some prepositional
formula over the variable survey which
which describes a set of let's say bad
States or other states and you want to
establish uh that on every execution uh
uh
as a state that belongs to uh to this
set is never visited
so this is very uh easy to uh to encode
uh uh into a salt problem uh namely we
are going to encode the
uh the the the the the existence of a
counter example so the reachability of
that uh by uh unwinding uh the the model
for for case steps so we have uh uh we
have K plus one uh copies of the state
variables and then we can set that uh um
the on the Zero initially uh the the
the initial State formula is satisfied
each pair of uh success uh successor
states have uh satisfies the transition
relation uh and uh the the uh the state
uh at position K uh belongs to the set
of uh best states namely satisfies the
formula the formula back
but it's clear that this formula is uh
is satisfiable even only if there exists
a path of length K that reaches her best
State uh so essentially a satisfying
assignment uh to the variables gives us
a counter example of length K to the uh
to our desired safety property and if
now the the formula is unsatisfiable
that means that we don't have a counter
example of length K so we can increase K
and continue searching for larger
counter examples
so this can be uh uh this uh um there
can be extended uh Beyond um beyond the
safety properties to handle uh all uh
LTL formulas with suitable encoding uh
and this was uh uh at the end of the the
beginning of a bounded model checking uh
that started with the seminar seminal
paper uh at tacos 99 uh by beer simati
Clark and uh
so I thought that this can be uh
extended uh uh to to General uh
temporologic formulas uh just uh as an
another as another quick example
um it can be easily extended uh to
counter examples to eventually reaching
some set of uh goal States uh and the
counter example uh which uh is uh has
the form of a lasso path uh can be uh
encoded uh uh into that similarly as
before so we have the enrolling of the
transition relation here starting from
um from the initial States uh but only
here we have to state that there is a
there is a loop somewhere uh and uh that
uh the there is a loop to some of the uh
the previous States from from the stated
position okay and that none of these
states uh visits the the goal
uh so this can be extended to full LTL
and furthermore uh bounded model
checking can be used for verification by
choosing a large enough large enough
okay
um namely for every final State model
and LDL uh property if either exists the
so-called completeness threshold
which
allows us to uh to conclude that a model
satisfies the formula if we don't find
the counter example of a size up to that
up to that completeness threshold uh and
the the issue here is that this case
typically uh very large
and uh so it's it's impractical uh to
use uh uh uh in in the Practical uh
applications uh but um
nevertheless bounded model checking uh
is uh is a very powerful uh uh technique
for uh and can be used for for
falsification uh namely finding uh uh
finding counter examples
uh further uh complete uh salt-based
techniques have emerged uh based on the
the idea and similar ideas as a bounded
model checking namely induction
abstraction interpolation and ic3 I will
not go into uh detailed discussions of
these techniques here because I want to
move to two synthesis at some point
what I want to emphasize is the impact
of bounded model checking uh namely
abundant model checking is a widely used
uh since its introduction in the Eda
industry uh and uh the uh the the work
uh by beer at all that introduced the
bounded model checking has received a
range of very uh solid and prestigious
Awards such as the uh kafa 2018 award
etabs 2017 tested time award and the
most influential paper for the first 20
years of tacos award
uh so uh with the uh with that uh I I uh
I gave you a brief uh overview of a
sub-based uh verification and uh uh
convinced you hopefully that uh uh that
um
uh uh base verification techniques uh uh
are one of the the core engines uh in uh
uh informal verification uh and uh with
the with that I will uh now proceed to
the topic of uh reactive synthesis
so one of the uh the drawbacks of a
verification is that it's applied only
after the system has been uh has been
implemented so we need to have an
implemented system in order to uh to
verify it
so the goal of synthesis is is more
ambitious uh namely to construct an
implementation automatically uh from a
high level specification
Now by by construction uh the system
will be correct with respect to that
specification provided that we have
written a specification that that
actually accurately captures uh Our
intention uh and
even if uh it turns out that there
exists no implementation uh for uh for
the specification uh this is still
valuable information especially in the
early design phases because one can
establish that uh the the for the the
specification is unimplementable and
therefore needs to be uh to be revised
uh so a synthesis a procedure takes a
formal specification sorry that that
specifies the behavior of the system
that we want to to synthesize uh and it
determines that the specification is
realizable which means there exists A
system that implements a specification
or determines that the specification is
unreal realizable namely there exists no
no such implementation
now in this talk I will focus on
reactive systems particularly for final
State reactive systems which have a
continuous interaction with with their
environment so those are non-terminating
systems uh which kind of in a
synchronous minorities have a read input
from the environment and produce produce
output
and the specifications uh will be
will be
formalized as a linear temporologic
formulas or also Omega but here I will
just consider a linear temporologic
formulas
now the the reactive synthesis problem
has uh its Origins uh in the 1960s uh
when it was formulated uh by Church
um with the uh and the the uh the
problem statement that given a
specification the Phi over sequences of
evaluations of input and output Boolean
variables uh we wish to construct a
final State implementation or of a
circuit that satisfies the specification
for all the possible infinite sequences
of input values
no uh uh so as uh as I said you can
think of a reactive system as a system
which uh reads uh input at this type and
produces uh produces outputs at the
corresponding stack
uh now this uh type of uh our system
model has a range of applications uh uh
starting from uh the design of a
communication protocols uh
nowadays also uh in robotic motion
planning for uh synthesizing kind of
high level uh controllers for robots or
other autonomous autonomous systems in
high level because here we are again
talking about the finite State systems
um so essentially uh Finance data
control
now let me give you a a quick example uh
which is one of the classical examples
and namely uh an Arbiter so suppose that
we want to synthesize an Orbiter that
serves uh to client processes uh so
there we have to input variables R1 and
R2 which model the requests and we have
to Output variables uh G1 and G2 which
model the grants that the Arbiter gives
to the two clients respectively
uh now our specification states that the
two grand should never be given
simultaneously and also uh what we want
is that every request uh our eye is
eventually uh followed by a grant uh GI
uh this uh these two uh properties so
our specification is the conjunction of
these two properties and they can be uh
formulated uh expressed in linear
temporologic uh as follows so this box
means globalist or something should hold
it at every step and the diamond means
eventually so at some point in the
future uh and so what this this formula
States is that uh globally it's not the
case that the two grants are given
simultaneously uh and also globally if
we have a request order at some point in
the future uh there is an output GI
uh and one very trivial implementation
of such uh such an Armature is one that
completely disregards the request and
then just uh gives uh grants uh to the
two processes in a round robin fashion
so this is a very trivial implementation
and in reality one would wish to uh
include further
constraints in order to uh to prevent uh
such implementation if they're
undesirable
now uh after since it's a introduction
initially there has been uh mostly uh
kind of theoretical developments uh um
in the area of reactive synthesis uh so
a beauty and London showed uh how the
automatic Transformations the problem
can be translated uh to a two-player
game and merely and Rosner later
considered uh the problem the synthetic
problem for LDL specifications so the
original problem was essentially
formulated uh for uh specification in
s1s
uh and uh they also established that so
that the the reactive synthesis problem
is is hard namely uh the LDL synthesis
problem uh uh is 2x time complete in the
size of the specification so if you
think that that NP is a difficult uh
well this is uh
uh like we're looking at problems that
are uh to extend complete
so uh that's one of the the reasons also
for which uh for a long time there was a
kind of no uh real uh kind of
developments uh uh uh
kind of towards more practical uh
Solutions uh but in the last uh two
decades there has been uh many uh
efforts towards actually uh bringing uh
reactive synthesis closer to uh to to
practice and to practical applications
so one of the kind of major uh
developments uh was uh
um by petermannatal
identifying a fragment which is exp of
LDL which is expressive enough uh but
has a better worst case uh complexity
and this fragment is also the the the
specification form is quite intuitive
and then is used uh in a number of kind
of applications in the uh robotic uh in
a number of robotic applications
uh so
um well in addition to that there has
been a very active development of uh
techniques uh starting from under
obstructions composition no techniques
and so on uh and uh and also resulting
from that uh also synthesis uh tools uh
and uh since uh 2014 uh there is an
annual uh since competition uh for uh
reactive synthesis tools
now in terms of in terms of tools there
are a number of tools that are based on
on bdds that manipulate uh kind of sets
of uh sets of States uh represented as
uh as bdds and this is quite natural in
the setting because synthesis involves
the end of this inevitable uh quantifier
alternation between uh
between the uh like for the respectively
for the input and output so for every
input uh there exists an output at the
corresponding
well Corner story step uh and uh because
of the the abilities support for uh for
quantifiers uh that this makes them a
natural choice and a lot of a lot of
synthesis tools are based on the kind of
using bdd engines
uh more recently there has been also
active development of uh satisfiability
based synthesis methods and tools and in
particular kind of inspired by by the
success of a sub-based verification
so one of the uh the uh The prominent
approaches is the bounded synthesis
approach biting
uh where one looks uh at uh switches for
implementations of a given bounded
abounded size and this allows for
essentially encoding uh the problem as
as a constraint as a dissection problem
uh and there are a range of of other
techniques uh some of them had
restricted to uh to safety specification
for instance for like you know using qbf
and nsat solvers uh and combined with
learning to to compute kind of the the
set of uh who the winning region for uh
for a player in in a safety game
um however uh one of the uh the most
reads uh recent synthesis tool tools uh
namely uh streaks
um uh which which implements an explicit
method uh actually uh outperforms uh the
uh the symbolic uh the symbolic
synthesis tools uh since it's a
participation in the in the uh scene
comp competition uh starting uh 2018
since when the Tool was uh was developed
so in in some sense in this setting end
of her uh a tool which doesn't uh
exploit a kind of symbolic
representation uh is uh at least on the
Silicon benchmarks uh more performant uh
uh than uh than other uh symbolic um
symbolic techniques uh for synthesis
uh I will uh now uh go on to uh to
explain uh why we are still interested
uh in uh considering uh symbolic
techniques and in particular sub-based
techniques
um
and uh like why that that gives us a
power to uh to address uh kind of
interesting challenges in synthesis but
first let me talk quickly
um
explain the the idea of a bounded
synthesis for for LDL specification uh
so the um
the high level idea is uh to as I said
kind of to
um look for implementations of unbounded
size uh and uh and then code uh the
existence of such an implementation uh
uh as a as a thought problem uh or I
think in the so the in the initial
formalization they uh they did that as
an SMP problem actually
so the the idea is that uh the formula
is translated uh to a universal copy of
automata and I will not discuss uh this
part uh here because
there is uh the time does not allow and
uh it's uh not critical for what I want
to to talk about next
the The bounded synthesis procedure uh
uh constructs uh a constraint system
which asserts the existence of such a
transition system with uh with the
number of states in the system uh at
most of the given Bond uh and uh
ah and also asserts uh the uh the
existence of a so-called annotation for
the automaton and the system uh which
you can think of it as some kind of uh
uh witness that certifies that uh the
specification is satisfied again I will
not go into the technical details here
now in the as I said kind of in the
initial uh formalization uh
well I think Panda and Chevy considered
an smt encoding with the bounded
integers and they used uninterpreted
functions uh to uh to form to to express
the uh the system and the the transition
relation of the system and its outputs
and and uh the uh The annotation
uh but uh actually uh in a follow-up uh
work uh they compare different uh uh
encodings namely uh a certain coding
where uh the includes and and the states
of the system are represented explicitly
uh a qbf encoding which is kind of more
symbolic namely the
um
the the uh the inputs are are symbolic
in the sense that uh so here we have
like in the certain coding there is uh
uh a conjunction over all the possible
uh inputs at a given uh step while here
uh those are Quantified uh and uh dqbf
encoding where both the inputs and the
states are symbolic and their results uh
which you can look up uh in in their
paper show that uh kind of the qbf uh uh
encoding was the most uh um the the most
had the better performance uh for for
the benchmarks that they consider
so I I I told you that yeah so although
uh kind of explicit synthesis May
perform uh perform better at least on on
the the benchmarks that uh well that is
a part of the syncom competition uh the
satisfiability based uh
synthesis reactive synthesis techniques
are allow us to to make use of
techniques beyond the Set uh in order to
to address some of the challenges uh in
the area of reactive synthesis
and I will now uh uh go into into that
which is uh
on the the third part of my talk
so one uh of the challenges uh uh of
synthesis as uh as I see it as in many
um people say it is uh the the challenge
of writing specifications
so uh it is uh it is critical that uh
that the specification uh that describes
the behavior of a system uh captures uh
all the the assumptions on the
environment that we had and uh and also
uh doesn't
um that doesn't include the requirements
which are which are inconsistent or
cannot be said cannot be realized uh
together
and this is often difficult if you have
uh requirements that that come from from
different sources or they describe
different uh different features of your
system uh and uh you you do have to uh
to consider them together although there
might be turn out to be inconsistent uh
and also identifying a a good set of
assumptions on the environment is also
is also quite challenging because those
assumptions should not be overly
restrictive for the environment but on
the other hand uh must still kind of
capture the the the any assumptions that
are really needed for uh for the
specification to be to be realizable
uh so that what that means is that
oftentimes if we write a specification
uh then the synthesis Tool uh comes back
and says that the specification is uh uh
is unrealizable uh and uh as I said kind
of in that that setting one would look
at uh uh perhaps a counter example which
is a strategy for for the environment
and identify uh how the specification
might need to be uh to be revised uh but
in other cases we might want to
um uh
synthesize uh an unimplementation uh
which
which in some sense uh kind of relaxes
uh relaxes the guarantees uh on that uh
the the implementation must satisfy but
still in in a way that is uh uh that is
transparent and that is uh uh
um
that is in some sense meaningful
so let me make this a little bit more
more concrete uh so now we have another
another Arbiter uh example uh which uh
however now uh instead of this response
property uh we said that the ground
should be given eventually or it states
that um that the ground should be uh
give every request should be granted in
in The Next Step so clearly this
specification is unrealizable because
the request can come in simultaneously
and there is no output that can satisfy
uh both of these requirements
however there exists an Arbiter that can
grant each request within two steps I
mean we saw an implementation of such a
trivial Arbiter
um a few slides a few slides back so
that that's I think we would uh like our
synthesis procedure to uh perhaps
produce such give us back such an
implementation with the clear kind of
indication uh What uh what properties
this implementation has right so it
should not be some arbitrary relaxation
of our of our properties more concretely
we would like to have to attend an
implementation which is guaranteed to
satisfy the specification as well as
possible with respect to some precise uh
meaning behind the notion of as well as
possible and I will show you one such uh
case in a couple of slides
now let me show you another example uh
which illustrates a kind of a different
aspect of of
um
unrealizability uh now we have an
Arbiter which I call a patient Arbiter
again we have our mutual exclusion
requirement uh but and and we have the
normal response properties such that
grants should be given eventually for
every request
uh but uh that there is the additional
requirement which says gives the name a
patient to this Arbiter is that a ground
should not be revoked while the client
keeps requesting it uh provided that the
client will eventually release the
branch or we will drop the uh the
request and this can be specified as
follows uh so it should be that globally
if if the grant is given to uh to client
I and there is the request by client I
is raised but there is the
um the problem is that eventually this
request will be lowered now uh the the
the the ground should still be given in
the in the next in the next step
how can this specification isn't
realizable because the client might
never lower the might never lower the uh
the request
and uh therefore the the request by the
other client uh can never be answered
however this specification becomes
realizable if we assume assume how that
teacher that each client either releases
a grant within some fixed known number
of steps so it keeps it forever let's
say uh we and like the the our arbitrary
is a final set machine and also if the
client are financed it uh then uh we
know that if uh the the request was not
lowered uh uh within certain number of
steps it will never be uh it will never
be win over
so under such uh assumption uh this
specification is realizable by A system
that waits for the respective number of
steps and then gives uh then takes away
the Grant from that client and gives it
gives a grant to the other client if
needed
so uh in order to uh uh to um to do uh
kind of uh formulate uh this type of uh
this type of setting in the synthesis
problem we ask for uh the from the
synthesis of approximate implementations
which are guaranteed to satisfy the
specifications for uh for some sequences
of input values that belong to a given
class
um or we can even relax this further by
asking that at least a specified portion
of the sequences uh in in that uh for at
least a satisfied specified portion of
the sequences uh uh in this given class
the specification is is satisfied now
that so here this is some kind of
assumption on the environment but we do
not make an assumption in the form of uh
kind of some kind of logical assumption
on the behavior of the the environment
but it's more of a structural uh uh
assumption uh that will capture uh the
cases that uh now the case that we saw
on the previous slide with the patient
with the patient arbiter
uh and uh so now I will briefly uh
present to you kind of how we can uh
address uh these two are these two
problems namely the the problem of
synthesizing an optimal implementation
and the sentence the problem
synthesizing approximate implementation
uh by leveraging uh the on this uh and
the encodings of the bounded synthesis
problem uh into
um into uh
satisfiability and Beyond uh
or formalizations
now uh for uh for uh my uh now quick
operator
um uh I
I told you that uh the the existing
implementation which satisfies uh uh
every uh request within uh within two
steps but there are also other
implementations
um for instance those that kind of
Switched by prioritizing uh requests and
and ground them ground them in the in
the next step
uh in particular uh I can one possible
relaxation of this uh of this
specification here is one that uh that
says that it's not always that the
request is answered in The Next Step but
this happens infinitely often so each
for each of the the two clients the
request is answered immediately in The
Next Step infinitely often uh otherwise
uh uh like for other like for other
possibly infinitely many uh steps uh
this uh doesn't have to be the the case
uh and uh so in order to uh kind of
capture this relaxation formally uh we
consider a problem where we have a heart
specification so these are some some
parts of the requirements are hard
requirements and the other ones are our
soft requirements
and this gives uh end of this uh
so-called maximum realizability problem
uh where we are looking at we're looking
for an implementation uh that satisfies
the soft specifications as much as
possible
uh and so uh in order to to formulate
that precisely uh we need to uh kind of
associate uh we need to associate a
satisfaction value for an implementation
uh uh and uh and the formula uh which is
uh which has multiple possible uh values
with like depending on how much uh the
specification is is satisfied
so our specifications that we consider
are of this nice form so their
specifications of the form globally
something should should hold and this
naturally gives us these levels of
relaxation right when something is
satisfied always uh satisfied always
from some point on uh satisfied
infinitely often uh or kind of stops
being satisfied from some point at some
point on
uh and uh with that we can Define uh
this uh now this value function which
captures uh these these cases
and uh
uh now like We additionally we need to
uh to Define how this value how for a
conjunction of specifications the values
are are combined uh and um that we can
uh we can do again in in a formal manner
uh essentially how this is precisely
defined doesn't matter that much for for
the approach uh that I will show you in
this case we prefer uh that both of
these hold infinitely often versus one
of them always being true and the other
just being ignored
uh
uh so
uh the
yeah so these are just some examples of
of this type of value function but
essentially uh kind of what um what this
formulation gives us is uh now the
maximum realizability uh problem for
which we consider the bounded version so
we are looking for a transition system
uh that satisfies the hard specification
uh and um
uh and this optimal among uh the
um is optimal among all the transition
systems that are up to that that given
bound
uh and uh it's not uh surprising uh that
we can follow a similar uh kind of a
form of encoding as uh in the bounded
synthesis approach and now arrive at uh
at uh weighted uh uh at uh instead of
Assad problem arrive at a partial
weighted maxat problem uh and this
actually has kind of from uh uh from the
generation point of view and from the
like manipulation point of view it has a
nice structure uh because uh only some
some part of the uh
of the constraints have to be uh
um have to uh be as a soft constraints
associated with with race and it's it
it's also easy to manipulate them and
have different uh different combinations
of value functions uh as I showed you
before
so this gives us a formulation of of the
the uh this uh this maximum
realizability problem uh in for bounded
implementations as a partial weighted
max out problem
uh and uh um uh of course uh like the
synthesis problem is uh is hard the the
size of the instances that Max instances
that we have depend on the size of the
automata and the number of soft
specifications uh and uh they grow uh
pretty uh pretty quickly with uh with
the size of the the size of the
specification
um uh the the instances are part of the
the max out competition Benchmark set
and uh we we hope to kind of eventually
also from from the the encoding and the
synthesis side being able to to push
this further to more practical
applications
so I will
skip the the second part uh where we
have uh for uh the synthesis of
approximity implementations uh where uh
the problem is uh reduced uh to um
where the problem is reduced to uh to
maximum model counting but uh please
feel free to uh
look at the
look at the reference I should finish
now right yes so so my conclusion is
that uh yes we
um uh like we we know that kind of
verification has been one of the major
kind of motivations and driving
forces behind kind of the the
development of of more performance and
and better better thought solvers
um and actually verification uh really
kind of benefits from this performance
uh the use of satisfiability is always
in the context of synthesis of reactive
systems is uh still uh quite far from
the same level of maturity and
efficiency so kind of there is uh at
least not inside kind of uh like this
type of kind of industrial applications
that can really leverage uh reactive
synthesis and salt-based techniques for
that uh in the same scale as for
verification uh and uh uh yeah so the uh
but uh like with with the example that
uh that I showed you I hope that I
convinced you so that that advances in
in synthesis require uh effective tools
uh uh beyond that uh in particular in
the context of synthesis and of uh and
and in the context of synthesis with
quantitative guarantees uh optimization
plays an important role uh such as
techniques for uh for maxat or also for
maximum model counting which I didn't
have the time to talk about but yeah
thank you for your attention and
we have time for one quick question
thank you I'm very interested by the use
of the box and Diamond symbols in the
encoding are they just a convenient for
the convenience of talking or implies
that the underlying logic is Moodle
logic uh so the logic is uh temporal
logic so uh uh like the the the the the
the the
diamond and uh the the the the books are
the temporal operators so yeah so it's
uh so it's not classical order logic
over time
maybe Daniel I can set up here
any other questions